he says there's three things that drive
people
and you got to make a list and figure
this out he says make a list of what you
love what bothers you what you hate
so you make a list of those three things
what you love and you'll say I love my
wife
I love my mom
I love real estate I love this I love
that what bothers you what bothers me is
when people are late
what bothers me is when people what do
you hate oh I hate bullies
I hate manipulators like that's true
right and then there's a quote that says
whatever you don't hate you learn to
tolerate right whatever you don't hate
you learn to tolerate most people just
don't like their jobs they don't hate it
so they'll tolerate it yeah most people
don't hate their financial situation
they just don't like it if you don't
like it you'll tolerate it if you don't
if you hate it you ain't gonna tolerate
it you're gonna do you're gonna do
something about it so at this phase of
wanting to recreate oneself it won't
happen logically